they have the time that they start out
with
and the magnets will have
five minutes right
like this will have five Liam will have
four so we see the clock times above the
players those will be corrected in a
moment and it's just fast it's just
furious it's all about the speed and uh
as we saw in that doodle versus pregame
it's all about the mouth skills and
we'll see the moves come flying on the
board it's the Spanish opening which we
saw earlier today between these two
Magnus allows the open Spanish if black
captures in the center he does but
Magnus juice is a different variation
than the first rapid game of the day and
this is Mainline Theory this is very
well known stuff why it's porn stepping
forward now
will we see black capture in a moment on
this Square this is I think called the
Dilworth variation uh it's a very very
very tactical stuff Magnus has barely
spent any time Liam's barely spent any
time I've seen both players have this
position in Rapid games on the tour
right now there was a sacrifice there by
black but black has given up two pieces
in return he got a rook and two pawns so
if we do a count black is actually one
point up but White's minor pieces are
phenomenal white minor pieces are very
strong and I remember a game Magnus beat
Hans Neiman on the tour earlier this
season with the white side of this
opening I also remember that game I also
remember Liam lay also playing this with
the black pieces against Jordan van
forest and the two are still playing
into the main line this has all been
seen before like goes to the edge of the
board and the main line is actually for
the queen to move one square across the
diagonal to threaten to pin the queen
and Rook yeah I'm really surprised by
this decision by Magnus he's played into
an opening he knows that Liam has
studied in depth Liam has played all of
these moves almost instantly and it's
very theoretical black should be fine
Black's Pawns in the middle of the board
look great but uh yeah it's just so
complicated so uh hard to put a finger
on in terms of what the plan should be
often it's just move by move and there
is just about pure speed maybe Magnus is
playing on the clock but uh yeah I think
objectively maybe it would have been a
safer decision to play something really
kind of strange where he is simply
stronger than Liam especially with the
extra minute and I can tell you that by
Liam retreating that night he's gone
into his own preparation so no one had
ever played that move before and Liam
this is his home-cooked idea and he
moves his King to the edge of the board
getting out of the eye line of the light
squared Bishop this is a I think this is
a good Blitz approach oh Magnus however
is starting to create some threats so
Black's King is much safer now but it
did cost a valuable move a valuable
Tempo and White's Queen White's night
White's Bishops they're all perfectly
placed to attack those black Pawns in
the middle of the board all white needs
to do really is to start improving his
Knight at the bottom the White Knight
next to his king is not doing anything
that's why the bishop steps back the
White Knight is going to actually jump
to the square that that Bishop
previously occupied
so yeah it's very tense does black touch
any of those Pawns in the center of the
board if you touch those black pawns you
might weaken squares so yeah it's really
difficult for Liam the time situation
still more than a minute Advantage for
Magnus so that is already critical that
could play a huge part in the result
yeah and Liam facing pressure in the
center he has to defend his pawns so
that's why he steps forward with the
bishop it's a good move just breaking
the coordination between The Rook Knight
and queen
um Magnus will be itching to give up his
Rook for this bishop it's just I've
talked to Magnus enough times he wants
to sacrifice he hates his opponents
having nice Pawn structures he's going
to be very tempted to use his rook and
sacrifice it for the bishop doubling up
Black's Pawns in the center but I don't
think you should get carried away with
anything flashy here you just need to
play quickly keep the pace he's still a
minute ahead although that's ticking
down now the white Knights can move you
can protect one night with the other
Knight for example
you have lots of ideas here for white
but you just need to trust your instinct
slowed down he slowed down I I reckon
he's considering your move Rook takes
Bishop that's why he's paused for
thought and uh he's got his music on and
Armageddon you shouldn't get carried
away even if it's a strong move even if
sacrificing here
getting that black Bishop off the board
even if it's good why waste one whole
minute of an Armageddon game on that
just play a simple move move one of the
white Knights and he's now only got 20
second time advantage over Liam Lee and
he has to make a move
I I think he has to commit to something
you know I for me I would be
springboarding with my knight to G5 put
some pressure on that Bishop oh gosh she
spent a minute and a half on one move
it's Armageddon there's no increments
he's now down on the clock minus Carlson
and he has to win this game and then he
plays maybe the most natural move on the
board that he could have played this
instantly he defends one night with the
other one and uh now the Queens are
coming off the board however so we saw
an exchange Magnus shook his head maybe
that was just because of how slow he was
playing
he looks like he's still fine on the
board you can trade off the Queens if
you want to along that diagonal the
White Knight can move away
it looks like white is stable with his
minor pieces and uh called Liam's Pawn
on D5 is being attacked so he has to
defend that perhaps attack the bishop
the Knight sorry Knight jumps forward
also very good and uh yeah has a Time
advantage over Magnus that is going to
be huge that time Advantage it could
play a huge world of clock because it's
such a blocked position Suddenly It's
very similar actually in terms of
mentality to that prag versus due to
Armageddon it's going to come down to a
position that's blocked and it's just
about who's quicker on the mouse and
okay we do see an exchange of Pawns not
100 sure about that from Liam because
now it's slightly less blocked he could
have maybe just locked things down and
played on the clock but now can you kick
away White's knight from the center that
is the key Black's Rooks need to find
open lines in to get towards those two
white pawns on the left for example but
how do you do that if white stabilizes
if white secures his Knight in the
center then Magnus is just in control
and now it's Liam's turn to have a think
where he considers what to do and he
pushes the a pawn so he's got the same
idea as you David he wants to attack the
people but
yeah it may be too slow it's very very
slow and Magnus is now going to start
jumping forward attacking a weak Pawn
that black Pawn on the A5 square that
Liam has just kind of put there as a
Target Magnus is going to try and grab
it and suddenly it's Liam he's playing
with fewer pieces remember a rook is not
as good as a bishop at night so uh black
has two Rooks white has three pieces to
play with it's slightly easier the more
pieces you have in general despite what
the pawn count is and Magnus he's
insisting he's stubborn he's going after
that black apron
and uh now 35 second time advantage
yeah maybe the clock will decide this
game on the board it's still looking
good for white however that moment where
Magnus throws for one and a half minutes
maybe you spent the time well just uh
choosing a safe variation yeah and Liam
now under a minute
49 seconds on the clock and he's just
struggling both on and off the board
oh tricky time tea has to speed up I
mean regardless of what he has to do
okay so he gives up the a pawn fine but
just uh keep on making those moves keep
on putting pressure of Magnus now this
Pawn will be captured however uh Magnus
I think he's just going to take it back
with his own Pawn the one thing that
white should not do is exchange a set of
Rooks now if you take with White's Rook
then you're only left with your minor
pieces normally you want one of
everything you oh wow he really does
push his foot forward and capture
normally you want to keep pieces on the
board and Liam now complicates the issue
by throwing his Pawn forward now his
idea is to go for checkmate he's going
for the white king I thought he would
just exchange Rooks I thought maybe he
would be okay there but Magnus finds a
nice counter-attacking move rather than
Retreat the white Bishop he's forcing
off for Trader Rooks he has won two
Pawns in the process so now it's okay
to swap Brooks and now that those have
left the board Liam is left with a
ruined position he's down on material
he's down on the clock 20 seconds it's
not enough it's not enough no he and
look at him he just moves his King and
uh White has the dream position the
bishop and Knight are coordinating
beautifully and he captures a pawn I
mean more or less Magnus can play
anything because with 19 18 seconds left
on the clock there's nothing Liam can do
yeah he just lost the speed at the wrong
moment Liam and a couple of blunders
happened where he lost pawns due to the
situation on the clock and Magnus he's
reasserted control everything's uh
defended okay he grabbed another Pawn
it's just uh it was like Hungry Hippos
Magnus grabbed one point another pawn
another pawn another Pawn all of black
spawns have disappeared and Liam rather
than try and race on the clock she has
resigned Magnus takes the win wow what a
dramatic match
he takes